Kevin Durant we got to talk about this  he is coming to Gold State and a lot of  people say that you were the one that  made the difference that you got on the  phone and you told Kevin you've got to  come is that really true you know I  recruited KD really hard and you know it  was like the equivalent of a college  coach trying to get a top five recruit I  called him a minute although I would  have broke every NCAA rule there was I  called him a million times you just kept  calling him and calling him a million at  one time yeah and I tried to show up  wherever he was every chance I got and  that sounds creepy take a shower and  you're there you no wonder the Warriors  [Laughter]  when he just thought when I found out he  was coming I came back to my senses and  I said I want to do he respect me as a  man now when I just blew his phone up he  had to have a girlfriend who got on his  nerves worse than that before so yeah it  was a question myself  [Laughter]  you